movies especially by student filmmakers  should always be alternative in some  sense and our alternative category  honors films that experiment with  non-traditional storytelling and seek to  push the boundaries of our medium as the  makers of big hero 6 were especially  pleased to present the winners in the  alternative category both of which used  animation now the Academy received 128  entries for the alternative category and  the winning two films are curious cairo  by Daniel Drummond from Chapman  University in California a discovery by  a mysterious entity sets in motion a  chase through abstract space and Zoe by  chi hun lee from the School of Visual  Arts in New York it's the story of a  man's life from cradle to grave